- So I'm gonna talk about
inference in mathematics.
I'm a philosopher,
so this will be from a
philosopher's point of view.
(Windows sound)
I'm pressing the wrong thing.
Ah.
So I'm gonna talk about mathematics
and the general theory of inference,
deductive inference in mathematics,
and then non deductive inference.
So the talk is about
inference in pure mathematics
and mathematical inference can be,
is unusual in several respects.
And it's quite different from,
the talk is quite different
from the ones you heard this
morning and earlier today
because mathematics is,
mathematical objects for a
start, they seem to be abstract,
so numbers, functions, sets,
geometric shapes and so on
that pure mathematics is interested in
are not spatial temporal,
they're not causal,
they don't seem to be causal.
Therefore, mathematics
is not a causal domain.
So any kind of inference
in pure mathematics
is not gonna be a causal inference.
There are correlations in mathematics,
but the standard picture
is that all the
correlations are necessary.
You know, if certain spaces
have certain properties,
well, that's just a necessary fact
because they couldn't be otherwise.
And deductive reasoning proof
plays an outsized role in mathematics.
So a general theory of inference
has to cover mathematics,
as well as other kinds of reasoning,
you know, scientific
reasoning, everyday reasoning,
legal reasoning and so on.
So lemme give you an
example from epistemology,
Alvin Goldman in the late 1960s
came up with this sort of
short-lived account of the,
of knowledge, a theory of knowledge,
which stated that you know something,
if it's true, you believe it,
and you are causally related
to the fact in the right way.
Now this theory was not meant
to apply to mathematics.
It didn't apply to mathematics
because mathematics, as I just
said, is not a causal domain.
A theory of inference, if it's gonna be,
suppose you want to come up
with a general theory of inference,
should you have that ambition,
it's gonna have to cover mathematics,
which as I said is
unusual in these respects.
So just as a causal theory of knowledge
could never have been a fully
general account of knowledge,
a theory of inference,
which is just limited
to the causal inference
or to the physical case
is not gonna be a complete
theory of inference.
Oh, it went the wrong way there.
Okay.
Or did I go the right way?
I went the right way.
Okay, so like any other field, mathematics
exhibits two very broad
types of inference, right.
So this is just an obvious point,
you can divide it into deductive inference
where the conclusion logically
follows from the premises
or non-productive
inference where it doesn't.
And this is just a non-productive,
inference is just a catch-all category
that anything that's not deductive.
And I'm gonna take a closer
look at each with a sort of nod
to my research as prompted
by the organizers.
So what is deductive inference?
Well, premises necessitate the conclusion,
necessarily if the premises are true,
the conclusion also has to
be true, the starting points,
if the starting points are true,
then the conclusion will have to be true.
And our best theory of logical implication
or logical consequence adds something
to this necessation idea.
It takes the necessation to be true
to hold in virtue of form.
So here's a very simple
example of what I mean by that,
Ann is either American
or Brazilian A or B,
that's the form.
Anna, sorry, is not American, not A,
therefore Anna is Brazilian.
Okay, so there the premises,
if the premises are true,
the conclusion has to be true,
but not just that, it's in virtue of form.
Any argument that has that form
is also gonna have that
property, the premises,
well, the truth of the premises
necessitates that of the conclusion.
So a very natural thought
is that deductive inference
is a logical implication.
Now I've stated that very roughly,
and that sort of breaks
down to two halves.
The first half is that
when we infer deductively,
we move from some premise to,
or some premises to a conclusion
that these premises logically imply.
Okay, and that seems correct.
But the second, so I
put a tick next to it,
but the second half, the other
direction is not so clear.
In fact, I think it does not hold.
The second direction,
is that if some premises
logically imply a conclusion,
we can deductively infer the
conclusion from the premises.
Now there's one sense in which that's true
because you know, if you
can assume that you can,
you assume we have all
the powers that we need
to follow a logical implication,
then, and it holds.
But if you're not talking
about idealized versions of us,
but you know, human beings,
even just mildly idealized versions,
then that second equation
is not gonna hold.
And more importantly, we
need to sort of distinguish
between implication on the one hand,
which is a relation between statements.
And that's not an anthropocentric notion,
that's just
what holds a property
that some statements have
and collections of statements
have and others don't.
Some premises entail a
conclusion or they do not.
And there's inference,
which is something that an agent performs,
and which is anthropocentric
by definition,
even if we consider idealized agents.
So here's a kind of general question,
so what is logic?
Well, implication is the
realm of logic proper.
Right, implication,
the relationship that some
statements have to others
whereby they logically imply them,
like in the Anna example.
That's what logic is interested in.
Logic is interested in implication.
And what is that best
theory of implication,
by which I just mean?
I use that interchangeably
with logical consequence.
Well, in this, in the book
that Owen Griffiss and I wrote
that came out last year,
we argued that there's a correct logic
and that it's highly infinitry.
Okay.
So what does that mean?
Well, I'm not gonna go
into too much detail,
but one of the things it means is that
you can conjoin infinitely many statements
or disjoin them, standard logic,
you can only conjoin or
disjoin finite many statements.
And you can also, in infinitry logic,
you can also quantify over
infinitely many variables if you like.
Unlike a natural language such as English,
where sentences are a finite length.
And this actually builds
on work by a Alfred Tarski
and (indistinct), who's up next.
So the point here is that if you,
once you understand the difference between
implication and inference,
that sets you free,
it enables you to give a
count of logical implication
that isn't constrained by agents.
Of course, the only reason
we got interested in logic
was because we were able
to perform inferences.
But once you realize that logic
is not about what we can do,
but is about what follows from what,
then you can, for example consider whether
logic is infinitry, which I believe it is.
Now the logic of
mathematical inference is,
can call that your home
logic, if you like,
your home logic in a particular context,
which you use for deductive
inference in that context
is gonna have to be a sub
logic of the correct logic,
whatever that is, if you're
gonna reason correctly, okay.
And a home logic is an epistemic tool,
it's gonna be sort of
much more down to earth.
It might, for example,
be first order logic,
otherwise known as predicate logic.
So for those who don't know,
first order logic has
names A, B, C, so on,
it has variables X, Y,
Z, predicates, F, G, H,
Boolean connectives,
such as negation,
disjunction, conjunction,
and it has quantifies for all they exist.
And all its sentences are a finite plan.
And this is a very
standard logic of course.
And your home logic
is gonna depend on what
you're using it for, right?
So you might even use
just propositional logic,
which is just Boolean connectives.
So much mathematical reasoning
can in fact be modeled
by first order logic,
and not all of it, but a
lot of it can be modeled,
and magicians have pretty good
over the past century come up
with some good pretty good
models of mathematical inference
using first order logic, as
that's to say as reasoning
from first order stateable axioms
via first order logic appropriate rules
to first order stateable theorems.
Okay.
So you've gotta distinguish
the logic that you use
as a epistemic tool for inference
from the sort of correct
logic, which might be,
the home logic might be
just the tip of the iceberg
in a particular context.
Okay, now I wanna move
on to something else.
Setting aside the logic,
talked about the logic
and mathematical inference
in my overview of mathematical inference
that I'm giving you
inference and mathematics,
how should we characterize
the epistemology
of deductive mathematical inference?
What are axioms
and where do they come from
and how do we know them?
A traditional picture here
is the Euclidean paradigm,
okay, it's inspired by Euclid's
elements from about 300 BC,
and it sort of held sway for more,
you know, couple of millennia,
the elements being a synthesis
of ancient Greek geometry
and mathematics more generally.
And very roughly the idea is
in mathematics, what do you do?
You start from self-evident axioms
via evidence preserving rules,
and you thereby infer some theorems,
and you transfer the kind of evidence,
this kind of maximal degree of evidence
that the axioms have down to the theorems.
And as I said, this was
a very prevalent picture
of mathematical reasoning from Aristotle,
at least from Aristotle,
who actually comes a bit before Euclid
to the 17th century and beyond.
And there's a kind of,
in the 17th century, there's
a kind of Euclid mania.
A lot of people write books with a title,
the Euclid of this or
the elements of that.
Any form of knowledge has to be recast
in this kind of Euclidean
form for it to be respectable.
And today, Euclidean is
as a kind of paradigm of
mathematical deductive inference
is on the wane,
but it had some proponents
even though the 20th century,
and there's some people that
you might call near Euclideans.
And so Wes Wrigley and
I have reconstructed
and tried to assess this
Euclidean picture in this book
that's gonna come out next month.
So what is this Euclidean paradigm?
It can be expressed, we think
in these seven principles,
slightly simplified here,
that all axioms and
theorems are true, okay.
All axioms are maximally evident.
Maximal evidence is preserved
when you reason from
premises to conclusion.
As a find in this condition,
the axioms have gotta be finitely many.
The axioms have to be
general propositions.
As an independence condition
that the axioms have to be independent,
each axiom has to be
independent of the others,
that's to say if you had an axiom
that you could deduce from the others,
then it would be a theorem, not an axiom.
Then it loses it's axiomatic status.
There's no need to status
it as an independent axiom
and a completeness condition,
which is a kind of slightly schematic,
all truths of a certain kind
can be inferred from the axioms.
If you are axiomatizing
geometry and you've emitted
and you're not able to
prove a particular fact
that you already believe
about triangle, say,
then you need to
supplement your axiom set.
You're missing something.
This Euclidean picture no longer holds
in full generality
about mathematics today.
Well, truth still holds,
we still think our axioms
should be true of their
intended subject matter.
But truth here mostly takes
the form of stipulative truth.
Okay.
Think of the axioms of group theory.
The axioms of group theory
define what it is to be a group.
So they are true of groups,
but by kind of definition,
by stipulation.
If you think that one of
the axioms of group theory
isn't true, you've just
kind of misunderstood
what it is to be a group.
The self-evidence principle
doesn't apply generally
because in foundational
theories of mathematics,
such as set theory,
there are certainly some axioms
that are not self-evident.
The flow principle fails
for sort of general reasons.
Finiteness and generality usually apply,
but independence does not apply generally.
In standard axiomatic systems,
there may be some
dependency among the axioms,
for example, in the standards,
system of set theory,
there is some dependence
between the axioms
because, you know, other
criteria such as simplicity
and ease of comparison,
there a that kind of
override this independence
(indistinct).
And completeness fails we
now know for various reasons,
it sort of depends
on the version of
completeness that you go for,
but if you go for the sort of
highest form of completeness
where you can deduce either
a proposition or its negation
in a kind of a system other than a sort of
very simple axiomatic
systems, Godel's theorem,
Godel's incompleteness
theorem is gonna tell you that
completeness is not gonna help.
So what should replace Euclideanism?
Well, the kind of move
away from Euclideanism
introduces a couple of ideas,
first, the idea is instead of
talking about self-evidence,
think about intrinsic plausibility
or justification on a conception.
If you think of the structure
of the natural numbers,
you have a certain conception
then principles can seem
plausible on that conception
or not, likewise with sets.
And this actually, and
notice that this allows,
once you move from self-evidence
to intrinsic plausibility
or justification on a conception,
intrinsic plausibility on
a conception I should say,
you thereby allow for degrees
of plausibility as well.
And also extrinsic justification
should also be part of the mix.
So here's where pure mathematics
starts to look more like science.
Extrinsic justification
can be sort of divided
into two broad categories,
one is regressive.
So this is analogous to
the kind of justification
that's enjoyed by scientific postulate,
which predicts the data.
You've got some sort of mathematical data
in the mathematical case that
could be very simple claims,
you know, simple arithmetic
like two plus three equals five,
where it could be more
sophisticated claims.
And the idea is that an
axiom gets to earn its keep
by predicting some of these claims,
just as in those kind of scientific case.
But there's a theoretical form
of extrinsic justification
also exists and takes the following form,
that principles can enhance the simplicity
and economy and unifying
power of the overall theory.
And thereby, I'll kind of
justify it in that way too.
Okay, so talked about mathematics
and general theory of inference
and about deductive inference
and mathematics focusing on the logic,
and also on the axioms and
what justifies the axioms
and kind of the old picture
versus the new one that has emerged.
I want to end by talking about
non deductive inference in mathematics.
Okay.
So remember that non deductive inference
is a catch-all category
that encompasses any sort of inference,
and that's not deductive.
So there's some broad categories here,
for example, numerative induction,
sometimes people just say induction
when you infer from all observed A's,
having been B's in a very simple case
that all A's are being B's
from the observed cases of A's
having some property
to the unobserved ones
also having that property.
Or there's inference
of the best explanation
and very schematically
as a body of established
facts to be explained.
And these facts can be a
mixture of observations
and more theoretical claims,
and among the range of explanations,
except you should accept the best one,
that's what inference of the
best explanation looks like,
and it's not deductive.
Okay.
There's a caveat here about the
explanation having to be a good one.
So what about mathematics?
I mean mathematics,
how does mathematics rely
on non-deductive reasoning?
Well, there's some obvious
ways in which it does so, yeah.
I mean, for a start,
the choice of research
project, for example.
You should choose a research
project that's tractable
either a research project
for you or your student.
And by definition, the project
has the research project,
you haven't improved what
you might wanna prove.
Therefore, in the absence of a proof,
you've gotta kind of make a judgment
about whether it's
attractable project or not.
There's also what philosophers
called testimonial knowledge,
a justification.
So just like any other sphere of knowledge
outside mathematics.
Fermat's has last theorem, for example,
approved by Wiles Taylor in the mid 1990s
is a 100 page paper.
Only experts in the field can
read it and understand it,
but you and I know that it's true
because the experts are a
kind of reliable community
and therefore that knowledge
can be passed on to us.
And in fact, most mathematical
knowledge is of this kind,
you know, whether it's
sophisticated claims, proofs of,
such as the proof of Fermat's last theorem
or just simple ones for the
sort of lame mathematician
who knows Pythagoras's theorem
because that teacher told them it was true
or the textbook told them it was true.
There's also computer generator,
computer assisted,
computer verified proofs.
Really, this is just an
example of the former
because you're assuming
that the computer is,
the hardware the software is reliable
when you're relying on it
to generate some result
or some calculation.
And so 21st century mathematics
will be severely hamstrung
by a strict insistence on
deductive reasoning only.
I mean, this would be a kind
of sort of proof fanaticism.
Is there non deductive
knowledge in mathematics?
Okay.
By which I mean knowledge of
a mathematical proposition
without anyone having a
proof of it, not just,
you know, not even Wiles and Taylor,
but no one whatsoever, no
computer having come up with it.
So I take the sort of radical view
that you can know a proposition
without anyone having proved it.
So mathematicians don't like this at all.
In fact, mathematicians use the word
no in a mathematical
context synonymously with
it's been proved or we have proved.
So we've known since
2002, then such and such
because someone proved it in 2002.
But is that right?
So take an example from number theory,
Goldbach's conjecture
or the example of primarily
testing where you test the,
whether a number is prime
and then you can quickly convince yourself
with probability that with
probability one minus epsilon,
where epsilon is really
tiny, that it is prime.
So Goldbach's conjecture
states that every even number
is a sum of two primes, every
even number bigger than two.
So there's a lot of
enumerative evidence behind it.
Four times 10 to the 18
cases have been tested.
There's also evidence
that the number of ways
of writing an even number
is a sum of two primes grows
with that number, not in a
kind of linear or strict way,
but as an overall increasing trend.
That proves some very
slightly weaker theorems.
There's heuristic arguments
about the distribution of
the primes that don't prove
but suggest that the argument is true,
but that the Goldbach's
conjecture is true.
And there are also analogs
of Goldbach's conjecture
that hold in random models of the primes.
So the probability that
a number N is prime
is one over log-n.
And if you generate sequences of numbers
with that probability,
that's to say that number
n appears on the list
with probability one over n,
you get a kind of prime-like sequence,
and then you can have an analog
of Goldbach's conjecture for that.
And you know, a version of
Goldbach's conjecture holds
with probability one for these sequences.
It doesn't prove Goldbach's conjecture,
but it does tell you
what the class of those
sequences looks like.
Also, you could come up with
sort of philosophical arguments
to diffuse objections to this kind of idea
that you can know mathematical
claims without proof.
And one such argument
is based on philosophical
analysis of knowledge.
So I mentioned one
before, the causal theory.
And as I said, that one
doesn't apply to mathematics.
Or to put it positively,
it doesn't rule out
non-deductive knowledge
of mathematics either.
And if you look at the kind of,
the philosophical analysis of knowledge,
the things that have got
some sort of traction
in the literature over
the last sort of 50 years,
the 60 years that philosophers
have been thinking about this
in all detail, of course they
did think about it before.
But they sort of fall into two camps,
either they don't apply to mathematics
like the causal theory, or if they do,
they allow non-deductive
knowledge of mathematics,
for example, the classic case
of knowledge being justified true belief.
Not you can have
non-deductive justification
as in the case of Goldbach's conjecture.
And actually, if you think about it,
there's sort of non deductive reasoning
that's at the heart of deduction,
because as I said earlier,
axions are at least in part
extrinsically justified.
And this is a form of
non-deductive justification, right.
If you believe something
in part because it has
some nice implications
that you already believe,
then you're not deducing
it from some axioms,
that form of justification
is non-deductive.
And so abandoning this Euclidean
picture helps undermine
the sort of specialness
of deductive reasoning.
If there's some sort of
non deductive justification
behind some of the axioms,
then the kind of what's special
about deductive reasoning
has been undermined.
Another way in which there's
sort of non-deductive reasoning
at the heart of deduction
is that mathematicians rarely
give full proof, right?
Especially expert mathematicians,
they tend to give proof sketches.
And so your confidence
that a proof sketch can be
elaborated into full proof,
where does that come from?
If you give a proof sketch,
where does your confidence come from?
What does it depend on
that it can actually be
turned into a foolproof?
Well, just kind of your knowledge
that this has worked in the past
or that steps of the kind
of this size actually,
if you spell them out,
would actually be valid and so on.
So that's justified non-deductively,
that's just from your
experience as a mathematician.
So lemme summarize the four
things that I've told you
in my overview of
inference in mathematics,
any general theory of inference
should you wanna try and come up with one
has to cover mathematics as well,
which is unusual in several ways.
The second thing is
that deductive inference
isn't the same as logical implication.
I take deductive inference to
be something an agent does,
logical implication to be a
relation between statements.
And I think, and you
don't have to buy this,
but I think the latter is
this highly inflammatory.
The third point was
that Euclidean paradigm
no longer applies
wholesale to mathematics,
a kind of a different
picture of mathematical,
deductive mathematical justification
is now much more current.
And my fourth broad point was
that non-deductive reasoning
is prevalent in mathematics,
and is in perfectly good standing.
Thank you.
(class applauding)
- [Speaker One] (indistinct) question.
(indistinct speaking)
- Thanks, this is a
really interesting talk.
I was curious,
just because you've characterized
as Euclidean program,
do you think that there's
a central component
of diagrammatic reasoning
that's a part of,
I mean, at least as
Euclid originally did it,
that something that's important?
Because there's some people
who I think wanna characterize that
as possibly not being something
you can regiment in first order of logic.
So.
- Yeah, thank you, that's a
really good question, yeah.
So the Euclidean paradigm
or the Euclidean foundationalism
as I described it
didn't say anything about diagrams,
but Euclid of course,
in the elements relies,
very much relies on spatial
reasoning and on diagrams,
diagrammatic reasoning.
You can't really be convinced
of many of the proposition
unless you draw a diagram for yourself
or see it on the page.
And Euclid was criticized
for that in the 19th century,
and the late 19th century, especially
as kind of modern logic
started to be developed,
people realized that there
were all sorts of gaps
in his reasoning.
So a kind of a new ideal
for mathematical reasoning was born
whereby the steps in
mathematical reasoning
are actually logical or deductively valid,
and do not rely on diagrammatic
reasoning in any kind.
But I think the Euclidean,
the way I wanted to characterize
Euclidean foundationalism
was broader than that.
I think that's a very narrow way
and a very kind of relatively modern way
of characterizing mathematical reasoning.
If you wanna take in mathematic,
the history, much broader
sweep of mathematics
and understand why the
Euclidean picture had
was so important and what's so dominant,
prevalent for so many centuries,
I think you have to allow
steps in mathematical reasoning
that could be guided by spatial intuition
that are not strictly logical.
When I describe mathematical inference,
the deductive inference,
that's a kind of a modern,
a much more modern way
of thinking about it.
- [Speaker One] I would like,
should we move to T and we
can continue asking questions.
(Alexander chuckles)
So we (indistinct)
time, or maybe later in the day?
So thank you.
Thanks for having this talk.
- All right.
(Audience applauding)